- So, former President
Trump's impeachment lawyers
have left en masse.
A lot of people are saying
that they are leaving like rats
leaving a sinking ship.
In total, five respectable lawyers
have left the impeachment defense team.
This is really bad news
for former President Trump,
because the briefs in
the impeachment trial
are due very soon,
and the team was headed
by a respectable lawyer
named Butch Bowers,
who has experience
representing very
high-profile politicians.
In particular, he represented
former South Carolina
Governor Mark Sanford
when he went on his whole
Appalachian Trail-Argentina affair thing.
And Bowers didn't seem
to be a crazy person.
He seemed to represent Mark
Sanford reasonably well.
So, let's talk about why
all of these lawyers left
in part two.
So, subscribe, or I'll see you in court.